Bokas, Bokas, Bokas, Bokas, Bokas, Bokas.
Mr. Army, willst du mitspielen?
Wo ich dich gerade im Chat sehe.
Ich brauche ein paar Leute, die mitspielen.
Weil ansonsten werden wir wieder von irgendwelchen komischen Wallhackern und sonst was direkt geownt.
Ähm, ja gut.
Wenn du das nicht installiert hast, wird es schwierig.
Stripes, moin, willst du mitspielen?
Also ein paar Leute brauche ich noch hier.
Bashen, Alter, bashen.
Also wer mitspielen will, am besten schon einen, den ich geerdet habe.
Wäre ganz praktisch.
Bisschen Boomer Games spielen hier.
Jo, na dann.
Dann suche ich mal einen Server raus.
Ne, Moment, wie funktioniert denn das jetzt nochmal?
Battlefield 3, Leute adden.
Achso, ja, dann warte ich mal, bis du online bist.
Irgendwo hier kann man Leute adden dann, ne?
Ja.
Wie auch immer das genau funktioniert hat, das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Das kriegen wir aber gleich raus.
Das kriegen wir gleich raus.
Ecke Mensch, shit.
Excellent.
Oh, du hast jetzt den goldenen Keks hier.
Zum ersten Mal.
Huge.
Massive Keks.
Du hast mich nicht auf Origin?
Du musst mich doch auf Origin haben, hä?
Wenn nicht, schick mir einfach eine Anfrage und ich adde dich.
Hab die echt nicht auf Origin?
Hä?
Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Mr. Army hier.
Ne.
Sieht nicht so aus.
Wahnsinn.
Kannst ja Anfrage schicken, hat er richtig.
Ganz unten in den Requests.
Ah, da ist er.
Excellent, excellent.
Willst du mal auf eine richtig kaputte Webseite gehen?
Ne, das ist bestimmt
irgendwelche
DOS-Geschichten.
Da will ich nicht drauf.
Ach, guck mal, er ist auch am Start.
Ja, kann man auch adden, klar.
Wie macht man denn hier
nochmal ein Squad?
Wie hat denn das nochmal funktioniert?
Ich, ich, ich check's, ich check's.
Ne, warte mal, wie ging das hier nochmal?
Add, off, ne.
Create chat.
Ja, ja.
Chat, wie hat denn das nochmal funktioniert?
Wie hat man hier
nochmal Squads gemacht?
Hier drüber irgendwie?
Create chat.
Nein, ich bin nicht im Discord-Shop-Streamer, lul.
Kann man sich
irgendwie
blicken, wie das funktioniert?
War me Mr. Army.
Wo ist er denn?
Check's nicht.
Wie hat man hier nochmal, wie hat man hier nochmal
noch online?
Ich hab keine Ahnung mehr, wie das funktioniert,
wie man hier Squads macht.
Musste man überhaupt einen Chat createn?
Ne, oder?
Ich glaube, man musste
da gar keinen Chat createn.
Aber ich bin BattleLog jetzt echt
hier irgendwie drüber.
Also ihr seht, es ist einen Monat her, dass ich
gespielt hab, ne?
Create a match?
Was? Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Lul. Das war create chat, ne?
Select.
Wo ist, wo ist denn der Mr. Army?
Seh ich den nicht?
Warum ist der hier nicht drinne?
Die Hälfte, die hat doch die Hälfte wieder nicht geladen.
Ne, Platoon sind
Clans quasi, sowas wie.
Ne.
Das ist wieder zu dumm für F5.
Ich hab keine Ahnung mehr, wie der
Krampel funktioniert.
Aber ich stell mich einfach mal auf
Abwesen oder so.
Dann sieht man, was Sache ist und man kann nachjoinen.
Kein Schimmer mehr, wie das funktioniert.
Stripes, hab ich dich im Origin
drinne? Stripes, da ist er.
Stripes, da ist er. Guck hier.
Und wenn man hier Leute addet,
dann joint man zusammen?
Oder wie ist das?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung mehr, wirklich nicht mehr.
Das ist jetzt komplett, komplett random.
Kein Schimmer.
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie das funktioniert.
Leute, wir haben das doch,
wir haben das doch auch schon mal geschafft.
Wir haben auch schon mal hier Battlefield zusammen gespielt.
Ich weiß gar nicht mal, wie wir das gemacht haben.
Keine Ahnung.
So.
Gut, gehen wir hier drauf. Was anderes gibt's da?
Kark Island.
Conquest Large. Gibt's da nicht irgendwas
ordentliches?
Classics.
Okay, Rush Classics. Klingt doch schon mal ganz brauchbar.
Queue Nummer 3. Perfekt.
Leute, ihr könnt einfach über Origin gleich nachjoinen bei mir.
MrArmy und Stripes.
Joint einfach nach. Oder sagt mir mal, ob's funktioniert.
Wenn nicht, mach ich hier nochmal nen Chat auf.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, wie der Kram funktioniert hat.
Ach, guck mal. Der joint ja auch schon. Pok.
So. Wie gesagt, Leute. Ich hab nen Monat oder so, dass ich hier noch mal ein paar Sachen machen kann.
nicht richtig schlecht sacke zumindest 111 vorteil hat dass das game läuft das
game läuft halt erst mal ordentlich mit mir war das perf wie war das in
es war nicht perf overlay bf3 draw fps wie war das in bf3 noch mal render
draw fps render render draw fps 1 bam jawoll bashen alter bashen wie jetzt
die laute wobei ich glaube lautstärke ist durchaus in ordnung oder glaub lautstärke
geht sogar halbwegs klar so leute guck mal ob das mit dem nachjoinen funst
boah ich bin alter ich bin es ja überhaupt
nicht so gut ich bin es ja überhaupt nicht so gut ich bin es ja überhaupt nicht so gut
nicht mehr gewöhnt hier an was sterben die denn bitteschön hier
gar nicht rettest ja captain foggast join mal rein
lasst mal gucken ob es okay ich habe absolut kein plan mehr
oh nice hier huge res fuck alles klar geht ja gut los
ich glaube die überrennen uns ganz schön guck mal der erst 23.6 jetzt schon
ich weiß nicht vielleicht spielt er ja heli und geht voll ab oder m track oder
sonstwas das ist ja immer noch möglich alter oh gott wie ist denn meine maus hier
eingestellt alter monka s captain foggast ist am start aber nicht bei mir sondern im
anderen team okay ich glaube man konnte hier gar nicht mit squad so richtig
join sag mal leck das wie sau kann das sein wo ist denn hier mein captain foggast du bist bei den
captain foggast du bist bei den captain foggast du bist bei den captain foggast du bist bei den
attackern vielleicht kannst du vielleicht kannst du
switchen ansonsten versuche ich mal zu switchen man muss einfach auf die gleiche
zeit leute man braucht ja gar kein squad aufmachen hier auch ich kann auch denn
ich kann auch den chat und so wieder aus man das braucht man ja gar nicht
mister army ist am start das braucht man doch gar nicht man muss einfach auf die
gleiche seite und dann kann man sagen man geht in d oder so es ist ungewohnt
es ist ungewohnt dass man nicht mehr bleiben kann es ist kein slide
õrvon es ist kein slide
es ist kein slide ich mache mich imب kommen weil ich
ich mache mich im astronauts dell ist ja alles einerweise nicht in den mcom als
das Ja años 3
man da hinten rein? Okay, vergiss es. Ah, meine Maushand-Settings, null. Das muss ich irgendwie
umstellen, Clay. Mal gucken, mal gucken, ob ich überhaupt Gegner treffe. Okay, krasser.
Rüstung stellst. Nein, nein, nein. Das war das Battlefield-3-Movement. Das hat so seine
Tücken. Ja, nice. Also, wir sind, Leute, wer bei uns ins Squad will, wir sind Squad
India. Ich kann auch einfach ein neues gleich aufmachen. Wobei, Mr. Army ist nicht mehr
da. Ist er? Geh mal, da geh ich mal zu Fatal rein. Jetzt bin ich ein Juliet. Boah, die
Oberrennen sind heftig. Ich dachte, ich kann jetzt erstmal ein bisschen noob-mäßig hier
wieder einsteigen. Aber das geht ja, kannst du nicht.
Das hast du komplett vergessen. Punkbuster-Kick-Player? Seriously? Warum das denn? Ah, das musst
du starten. Kann das sein, dass du das nicht gestartet hast im Service? Man muss das ja
im Service starten, dass das funktioniert. Leute, hier ist ja 64 Mann schon Clusterfuck.
Wie hat man sich da gedacht bei Battlefield 2042? Das ist eine gute Idee. Alter, es ist
eine gute Idee, 128 Spieler zu nehmen. Aber gut, ich werde gerätzt. Ich bin ja schon
zufrieden. Wir aimen das hier mal kurz ab. Da stellst du ja... Sieht irgendjemand überhaupt
die Gegner? Läuft der Stream flüssig? Okay, alles klar. Ach nee, Moment, man muss hier
die ganze Zeit springen, dass man schneller läuft. Ich erinnere mich, Leute. Ich erinnere
mich. Huge. I member, I member.
Punkbuster A und B laufen. Ja, dann ist es komisch. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Ich wusste, dass
da einer steht. Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung wo, aber... Oh, da vorne irgendwo. Rein, rein
schnellstens. Rechts. Rechts ist er. Irgendwo. Irgendwo hier. Wo zum Geier kamen die denn
jetzt her? Sind die, sind die parachuted hinter mir oder so? Boah, wir müssen irgendwas anderes
spielen als 64 Spieler. Das überfordert mich jetzt.
Boomerhirn erstmal. Wenn ich das so lange nicht gespielt habe, ich brauch da immer ein
bisschen durch wieder reinkommen. Okay. Attack. Oh-oh. Oh-oh. Nice. Next. Wo ist das Auto? Weiß
ich was. Äh... Aber der Stream lag nicht, oder? Der Stream ist... Also Battlefield, Battlefield
3 braucht ja nichts an, an Leistung. Der sollte ohne Probleme laufen hier. Streamlacke. Hier,
läuft gut, ok.
Nice, GG Eats.
Hier sind sie doch, hier.
Was? Alter!
Battlefield-Hit-Rack!
Keck, wait! Habt ihr das gesehen?
Alter, Battlefield-Hit-Rack!
Lul, das ist ja schon der Wahnsinn.
Es ruckelt durch Explosionen, da kannst du nichts
gegen machen.
Ich hab den Eindruck, ich muss ein bisschen
hochstellen.
Ziemlich hinterher bin mit der Maus.
Aber gut, komm.
Wisst ihr was, Leute? Ich hab so lange nicht gespielt.
Wir müssen, ich hab jetzt eine Ausrede für
M16.
Wisst ihr, wie schön das in Battlefield 3 war?
Einfach eine Runde Defi-Spam
und schon easy.
War das der Gegner?
Einfach Defi-Spam und schon stehen sie
wieder alle. Keine zwei Stunden
hoffen, dass sich Gegner
nicht basht, während du wiederbelebst.
Ok, gib ihm, Leute.
Gib ihm.
Oh, ich hab rechts einen gesehen.
Bin mir nicht so sicher genau,
was ich gehittet hab.
Alter, ich treff nix. Irgendwas stimmt
in meinem... Oder ich bin Battlefield 2042
gewöhnt.
Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Wahrscheinlich bin ich Battlefield 2042
gewöhnt.
Jetzt ist es vorbei.
Da hat man sich dran gewöhnt,
dass man nix trifft und dass man ein bisschen
was trifft bei nix treffen und jetzt ist es
vorbei.
Hallo? Wo ist der?
Wo?
Die schießen mich vom Dach an, oder?
Schießen die mich vom Dach an?
Bam, bam, bam.
Heli-Bash.
Au.
Keine gute Sache.
In den Kopf. Nein, nein, nein.
Kopf raus.
Kopf raus. Jawoll.
Sehr gut.
Oh.
Ist das modded oder normale Version?
Das ist die ganz normale Version.
Das ist die
ganz normale Version, die man, die jeder
spielen kann gerade.
Was ist hier?
Was ist mit dem da los?
Auf, auf.
Pssst, pssst, pssst, pssst.
Schön definen.
Überbande.
Boah. Game, hör auf zu ruckeln.
Das Game ist so krass am ruckeln.
Du kannst ja nicht immer zielen.
Hier auf irgendwas.
Lebt der noch auf dem Dach oder nicht?
Oder?
Das wäre cool.
Gibt es eine Konfig Option zum abschalten?
Abschalten des geruckelts.
Moment, da unten ist was.
Wo, wo, wo?
Erst mal hinlegen.
Ypsilon ist es.
Ich denke mich schon irgendwie.
Ich drücke zwar Ypsilon automatisch.
Aber mir war gar nicht klar,
was ich für eine Taste gerade drücke.
Okay, nächste Runde.
Jetzt mal gucken, ob das jetzt ein bisschen
kontrollierter vonstatten geht.
Tja, ich hatte die Auswahl heute.
Ähm.
Gucke ich mir den neuen Patch Battlefield 2042 an.
Leute, es gibt ein Scoreboard.
Ja, stellt euch mal vor.
Guckt mal, guckt mal.
Seht ihr das?
Ein Scoreboard.
Das ist unglaublich.
Hexenwerk, dass es sowas überhaupt gibt.
Ich meine, es gibt schon kein Chat am Ende der Runde.
Das haben sie ja schon, haben sie ja schon weggelassen,
weil Ende der Runde immer, immer krass geflamed wird.
Nose Hair Candles, jetzt Attacker.
Auf, pass auf Leute, jetzt geht's, jetzt geht's drüber.
Es wird drüber geschlittert.
Chat, konntest du einstellen?
Nee.
Chat, konntest du nicht einstellen Ende der Runde?
Oder ist es was Neues, was mir noch nichts sagt?
Ende der Runde Chat?
Ich meine, du kannst hier Chat machen, so.
Pack Weight konntest du machen.
Aber Ende der Runde Chat?
Wie hat man das, und wie soll das gehen?
Du musst den Punkbuster Service neu starten.
Also starten in den, in den,
in den, äh, Services von Windows, dann funktioniert das.
So, au, äh, Granate, bam, das war klar.
Komm, ich hol dich, Kolej.
Wir müssen mal gucken.
Boah.
Nein!
Ja, was?
Huge Suppression, Poggers.
Poggers Suppression.
So.
Tja.
M16, würde ich dazu sagen.
M16.
Alles klar, M16.
Äh, was mit H ging das noch, während das Spiel läuft?
Kann ich mich jetzt nicht dran erinnern.
I don't know.
So, bashen.
Wo sind's?
Oh, stuck.
Bitte, random step, bro, I'm stuck, Joke einsetzen.
Oh, ich dachte, das geht, wenn ich einfach noch drauf spraye aus der Hüfte.
Nur Plus während am Ende nicht mehr?
Okay.
Ein Prozent.
Wollte ich mich veräppeln.
Wünsche für das nächste Battlefield.
Ey, was heißt das nächste Battlefield?
Das nächste Battlefield kam vor zwei Monaten raus.
Und es hat leider gesagt...
Ey, ich muss mich ans Q drücken gewöhnen.
Ich drück kaum Q, Leute.
Geht das, geht das noch jemand so?
Oh, oh, oh, ganz schlechte Idee.
Geht das noch jemand so, der vorher 2042 gespielt hat?
Dass man, dass man überhaupt...
Dass man, dass man sich abgewöhnt hat, Q zu drücken?
So krass, ich bin es null gewöhnt, Q zu drücken.
Okay, bashen, jetzt hier, bashen.
Jetzt geht's rein.
Da ist der nächste.
Shit.
Weggesprayt.
Aber, guck mal hier, bestes Squad, Leute.
Bestes Squad, easy win.
Burpel, dankeschön.
Für den Sub.
Äh, was spielen wir denn?
Sand Crossing.
Sand Crossing ist POG.
Oh, die Legehenne ist am Start, Leute.
Doppel, dual, multithreaded Legehenne.
Okay, nice.
Multithreaded Legehenne war am Start.
Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken.
Jetzt kommen wir da rüber.
Bashen, Alter, bashen.
Okay, nice.
Oh, wir haben einen Smokeman am Start.
Beste.
Easy win.
Oh, oh.
Legehenne!
POG!
Hast du noch Kontakt zum Kaboom?
Selten, selten.
Aber Granatenspam.
Genau, einfach Granatenspam drauf.
Easy win.
Oh, nee.
Die haben diffused.
Haben die...
Anzeige ist raus.
Warum diffusen die einfach?
By the way.
Diese MG's an den Booten und den Panzern,
diese stationären Dinger, die waren so schlecht,
dass sie hier...
Hä?
Wo?
Da!
In der Treppe war er drinnen gestucked.
Äh...
Was war das?
Ammo?
Wir könnten noch...
Wir könnten noch mehr Suppression vertragen.
War...
War Anti-Suppression nicht verbuggt?
War das nicht irgendwie verbuggt, Anti-Suppression?
War da nicht was?
Ich erinnere mich.
Ich dachte, Anti-Suppression ist irgendwie verbuggt.
So seit 10 Jahren.
Fuck.
Okay, jetzt nochmal durchzukommen ist schwierig.
Oh, oh.
Auf, streck deinen Kopf raus.
In the ass.
I get fucked up in the ass over here.
Ich campe mal kurz hier eine Runde.
Mir bleibt gerade nichts anderes übrig.
Oh, von hinten kommt was, Leute.
Von hinten kommt was.
Die wollen mich bashen, Alter.
Ich sehe es.
Ich sehe es schon.
Komm, hier.
Da sind doch noch mehr hier.
Und jetzt flankt einer rum.
Fuck.
Oh, oh.
Ja, klar.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
An der Seite, hä?
Okay.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt kommen wir ein Stückchen vor.
Gucken wir mal.
Schauen wir mal.
Da.
Ja.
Please.
Battlefield.
Hallo.
Ich möchte einfach nur drüber springen.
Wenn es, wenn es im Bereich des Möglichen ist.
Ich habe Schiss, Leute.
Ich verpisse mich.
Wo ist er?
Hier, keiner da.
Auf jetzt.
Lege Hände hier.
Lege Hände in Action.
Ach, wir haben es schon.
Hä?
Leute, wie...
What the...
Wann haben wir denn das gelegt?
Wait.
Keck, wait
Ich dachte, ich muss hier noch
Krasse
Stells-Action machen
Wann haben wir denn das geholt?
Habt ihr das mitgekriegt?
Wann haben wir denn das M-Con erwischt?
Okay, ich will mich ja nicht beschweren
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung
Hier ist noch irgendwo was drüben
Muss ich mal kurz ein Stückchen verpissen
Oh, da wird reingedroppt
Okay, A sollten wir eigentlich
Mit dem M-Track kriegen
Eins merkt man, Leute
Die
Wie soll man so sagen?
Die Abtastrate auf dem Server ist halt wirklich
Krottig
Das Witzige ist, die ist ja potenziell
In Battlefield 2042 besser
Aber in Battlefield 2042
Registrieren die Schüsse halt einfach nicht
Oh, oh
MonkaS
Oh
Boah, Alter, wie viele Granaten, Mann
Mr. Army own wieder alles hier
Oh
Nice, TRX
Leute
Oh, oh, ah
Guck mal, hier sind so viele Leichen
Wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen weiter hinter
Ich glaube
Boah
Wenn wir hier, wenn wir hier auf der Seite
Kommen wir nicht durch
Hier, nice, nice, nice, nice
Legehände, Legehände, Legehände
Ich setze mich jetzt da rein
Das hast du jetzt
Oh, nee, fuck
Ich wollte gerade Switcher auf die Mark genommen
Leute, rein da
Jetzt wird's gesprayt
Fuck, Alter
So eine Action hast du in Battlefield 2042 nicht
Welchem Server?
Ach, keine Ahnung
Der erstbeste, den du angezeigt kriegst bei Rush
Sag mal
Da krabbelt noch einer oben
Krasser Krabbeloos
Wo ist der Krabbeloos?
Nice, nice, der Krabbeloos
Guckt euch mal an
Guck mal, seht ihr das?
Seht ihr das?
Wie geil die Leute hier aufs Resen und Punktefarmen sind?
Konnte man eigentlich, nein, konnte man nicht
Ja
Ja, 64 Spieler Rush
Das ist, ist schon, ist schon
Knapp am Clusterfuck
Au, au, nein, nein, nein
Wo, wo?
Streck deinen Kopf raus
Ach, da
Jetzt hätte ich mal ein bisschen Burst schießen sollen, ne?
Aber das Gute ist, M16
Wozu brauchst du Burst?
Blank Action hier
Flankerino
Massive Flank
Irgendwo hier unten war doch grad einer, oder?
Oder wurde das auf der Map?
Wo ist der?
Alter
Die krass, die Sneaky-Leute
Guckt sie euch an
Einfach da in der Ecke hat er gelegen
Einfach in der Ecke
Eckenstelz
Hoch 10
Auf, auf, beeil dich, beeil dich, Mann
Beeil dich
Ey, das ist ja Battlefield 2042 hier direkt
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Alter
Battlefield 2042, das war richtig krass
Battlefield 2042 hier direkt
Wird Bad Company 2 noch gespielt?
Ja, aber deutlich weniger
Ja, leider hat Venice den Hype nicht
Äh, äh, äh, geschafft, ja
Das lag, da waren die aber mit, mit
Selbst dran schuld
Die hätten zum Beispiel Surfer anbieten müssen
Von ihnen
Anders funktioniert das nicht
Mit, mit gutem Rules
Alter
Von, von wo?
Ach, von der Straße aus
Na gut
Aber Battlefield 3 Kreise laufen geht eigentlich immer
Oh, nice
Huge Razz
Alter
Leute, ich
Okay, nice
Jetzt kommt von da noch einer
Der hat's jetzt auch gedacht
Ich weiß nicht genau, was mir passiert
Einfach gespawnt und den Arsch mit der Magnum geshootet bekommen
Und dann ist es so, dass man sich nicht mehr so gut fühlt
Oh
Das fetzt hier aber richtig rein wieder
Au, au, au, au
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, von wo
Shit, shit, shit, shit, shit
Von wo, von wo, von wo?
Ach, von der Anti-Air
Shit
An die hab ich ja gar nicht gedacht
Okay, auf geht's
So, verstecken
Erstmal, erstmal
Verstecken im Busch
Verstecken im Busch, das geht eigentlich immer
Busch, Busch-Stelz
Guck mal, du hast da unten
Null
Jaja, ist ja gut, reg dich mal ab
So, next
Next
Oh, das wird, das wird jetzt was
Hier durchzukommen
Oh, von rechts, von rechts
Ich renn einfach mal rum und retze ein bisschen
Alter, die sind hinter uns
Oh, shit
Ich seh gar nix, wo ist denn hier was?
Leute, ich hab legit
Keine Ahnung
Wo hier irgendwas geht gerade
Okay
Nein
Ah, da
Ach, da
Obvious, obvious
Das Reviven war so OP
Naja, aber das hat dazu geführt
Ja, das war schon OP, aber das hat dazu geführt
Dass die Leute das wenigstens machen
Nicht so wie in Battlefield 2042
Wir wollen Zen Crossing spielen
Au
So, YOLO, YOLO-Rest
Alter, rein da
Rein da, Leute, es muss klatschen
Bam, bababam
Granatenspam aufs M kommen
Macht sie platt
Oh, nice, huge rest
Ah, und mehr Rest
Restrain am Start
Ja, fuck, man
Alter
Das ist doch nicht normal
Ach, du Scheiße
Boah, und von der Seite weggerotzt
Richtig gachi-bass
Das ist richtig gachi-bass
Hier gerade
Okay, ich rede wieder wirres Zeug
Aber, Alter, ich krieg hier mal
Übrigens, das Reviven
Dass es nicht als Tod zählt
Finde ich auch sehr, sehr nice
Das ist auch wieder ein Anreiz, ja
Ich meine, es ist doch das Optimale
Aus beiden Welten
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, wo der Typ jetzt hin ist
Die Leute behalten ihre Kills
Und die Leute verlieren ihre Death
Das ist im Prinzip alle glücklich gemacht
Ich lauf übrigens die ganze Zeit im Kreis
Weil ich nicht weiß, wo ich hin soll
Gachi-Roll
Ich gachi-roll
Aber 5, ich will Sandcrossing spielen
Wie wir früher gesagt haben, ahnungslos
Seine Crossing
Leute, was
Seid ihr Sandcrossing
Spieler
Oder seine Crossing-Enjoyer
Seine Crossing-Enjoyer
Sandcrossing
Sandcrossing, ja
Die Aussprache gab's auch noch
Sandcrossing
Ich muss mehr Q drücken, Leute
Ich drück überhaupt kein Q
Guck mal hier, hätt ich mehr Q gedrückt
Hätt ich gleich gewusst, dass ich hier
Durch den Smoke Leute sprayen kann
Einfach durch den Smoke sprayen
Oh, da hinten ist was los
Da hinten ist Gachi-Roll
Ist da in der Ecke
Ich hab's genau gesehen
Richtig
Gachi-Roll
Gucke, seht ihr denn
Sind's
Jetzt so Webster aufs Dach
Okay nice, nice, niceo, niceo, niceo
Aber da sieht man, dass diese Specialist's
Äh, Powers
Zwar vielleicht nicht ganz cool
Spassig für den Einzelnen spielen
Aber halt für die Struktur der Map
Und ähm
So das normale Battlefield Gameplay
Halt gar nicht mal so
Sinnig sind, ne
Alter, hier wird wiederbelebt
Hier wird wiederbelebt
belebt auf Doom. Was? Wo ist der Typ? Oh, da ist noch mehr. Da hinten ist er. Da hinten ist noch einer. Guck mal hier. Der Gachi bust uns von hinten. Das fand ich auch cool. Dieses Springen und Rassen dabei. Bam, bam, bam. So muss das sein.
Oh, die sind immer noch da. Ich wollte messen. Kickweight. Hätte ja funktionieren können. Es hätte ja klappen können.
NA-Aim. Ja gut, das kann man jetzt von mir nicht anders erwarten als 37-jähriger Boomer. 37-jähriger Boomer, dafür geht es noch durchaus in Ordnung.
Ja, das war halt typische Battlefield-Rasses. Mal geht's, mal geht's nicht. Die letzte Base ist schwer.
Ähm, passt mal auf, wir machen jetzt den Big Brain Play schlechthin. Ich zeige euch mal den Massive High IQ, Only 150 IQ Plus Play für die letzte Base.
Passt mal auf, werdet ihr gleich sehen.
Six Head. Eleven. Twenty-Five Head.
Was zum? Wo?
Okay, Only Five Heads. Only Five Head Plays.
Das geht aber nicht, weil die Leute im Stream gucken. Nein, wir wollen Sandcrossing spielen. Wir sind Sandcrossing-Enjoyer.
Oh ne, der hat meinen Five... Hallo?
Der hat meinen Five-Head-Plan zunichte gemacht, weil er mit dem Schiff langgefahren ist.
Der Bänder-Babber.
Der eigentliche Eleven-Head-Play ist hier langschwimmen und dann hinten rausstelzen am Wasser.
Das geht natürlich nicht, wenn die Leute dort mit dem Boot am Start sind.
Oh oh.
Okay, jetzt Six Head. Only Six Head Plays.
Oh oh, da ist ein Typ. Oh ne, das ist eine ganz schlechte Idee.
Die Seite ist schon komplett voll.
Jawohl, jetzt sind sie abgelenkt.
Nein, nein.
Was bist du noch im Boot?
Was bist du noch im Boot? Du sollst gefälligst das M-Com diffusen.
Anzeige ist raus.
Ah, hier können wir deployen.
Massive.
Nein, Battlefield, so ist das nicht.
Wie der Fallschirm funktioniert.
Ich glaube, das war Server-Lag, der uns gekillt hat.
Bin ich auf diesem... Kann es sein, dass ich auf diesem komischen Mast gelandet bin?
Boah, Alter.
Fünf Schmilliarden Gegner.
Muss er vielleicht fünf schreiben, anstatt Slash-Fünf zu machen?
Ich glaube, das G-Baitet uns einfach nur zum sinnlos Reintroppen hier oben.
Das hat, glaube ich, gar keinen sinnigen Mehrwert hier.
Ja, wir sollten, glaube ich, lieber hinten spawnen.
Ey, du.
Danke für die Subs, Leute.
Ich kann gerade nicht gucken.
Ich sehe nichts.
Hier, Six Head, Six Head Time.
Leute, Six Head Time.
Wehe, du bist wieder in diesem komischen Schlauchboot drinne.
Six Head Time.
Die stehen da mit dem Auto, ich fasse es nicht.
Oh, ne.
Oh, in der ist geschudet, Mann.
Ey, krass, in der ist geschudet.
Oh.
Okay, hier kannst du nichts machen.
Okay, hier ist mir...
Oh mein Gott, hier ist mir viel zu viel los.
In der ist...
Ah.
Aber das war erfolgreich.
Nicht so sehr erfolgreich für das M-Com.
Ja, es gibt noch Venice Unleashed, aber die haben es leider ein wenig verkackt.
Du entschärfst hier nicht, Kollege.
Jawoll, komm, M-Com.
Pregge, prege, prege.
Jawoll, wir haben es, nice.
Erfolgreich gepregget.
Ich muss mal gucken, vielleicht kann ich unseren M-Track reparieren.
Nein, nicht wegfahren, Alter.
Okay, unser M-Track ist down.
Nein, unser M-Track ist nicht down.
Massive M-Track Rap.
Ne, das ist der Jeep.
Der Boomer-Hirn macht es nicht mehr mit, Leute, ist vorbei.
Nee, jetzt, äh, Venice hat keine Spieler mehr.
Hier.
Ich, ich gehe in unseren M-Track, dass ich den rappen kann.
Boah, hier ist ja so Action, Alter.
Das ist ja nicht normal.
Charge has been set, sehr gut.
Gehen wir mal ran, wenn der Charge gesettet ist.
Lass mich rein!
Aber wir könnten, wir könnten es durchaus kriegen.
Ich bin gerade richtig, richtig heftig rein.
Gachi-Bass.
Alter, ich sehe nichts.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo hier überhaupt was abgeht.
Äh, ja, wenn die Server abgeschaltet werden,
dafür ist Venice natürlich richtig nice.
Wenn es abgeschaltet, äh, wenn Server abgeschaltet wird,
dann kann man mit Venice halt noch weiterspielen.
Dann kann man mit Venice halt noch weiterspielen.
Das hat das Game auch wirklich verdient.
Also damit ist das Game ja quasi unsterblich, wenn man so will.
Oh, da sind ganz schön viele Leute.
Au.
Oh, von hinten.
Oh, oh. Oh, ne.
Ich wusste nicht, ob ich auf
drei oder vier mein RPG habe.
Wo habe ich mein RPG?
Drei oder vier? Ich spiele es zu wenig.
Ich spiele auch viel zu selten Engineer.
Oh, ne, jetzt ist er down.
Jetzt ist der M-Track hinüber.
Da machst du nichts mehr.
Es ist aber halt ziemlich kacke, hier reinzukommen, so.
Boah, wo fängt jetzt das...
Da muss ich mal reintropfen.
Keine Chance.
Das geht nicht.
Wir müssen uns irgendwie normal aufbauen.
Das wird nicht...
Das badet höchstens die Leute rein.
Einmal weggeguckt, direkt deadge.
64 Spieler Rush ist einfach zu viel.
Ja, dann denkt man sich so was.
Haben die sich bei DICE gedacht mit 128
bei einem Breakthrough?
Soll ich euch sagen, was sie sich dabei gedacht haben?
Nichts.
Nichts haben die sich dabei gedacht.
Gachibas haben die sich dabei gedacht.
Da kommt jetzt gleich noch mehr hier, Leute.
Ja, das hast du dir so gedacht.
Ach, der Dude lebt noch.
Nein, ich habe die Taste gar nicht gedrückt.
Leute, wir haben es nicht.
Wir haben es verloren.
Oh, nein, nein. Okay, okay, okay.
Alles draufschmeißen, Leute. Alles draufschmeißen.
Yes.
Wir haben es. Wir haben es. Wir haben es, oder? Haben wir es?
Bam.
In your face. Nice.
Alter, Corona schlägt zu.
Der Server war überfordert.
Warum war der Server überfordert?
Es lief doch halbwegs flüssig.
Ach so, das meinst du. Hittrack.
Ja, das hatte ich zwischendurch auch.
Die Musik im Hintergrund.
Was kommt denn als nächstes für eine Map?
Ich hoffe, Zen-Crossing.
Seine.
Seine Überquerung.
Dammit, P-Crush. Auch gut.
Hm.
Sehr gut.
Exquisite.
Zen-Crossing, Leute.
Excellent, excellent.
Warum kann ich eigentlich keine Vollbild-Memes einblenden?
Sag bloß, ich spiele nicht im Fullscreen.
Alter.
Wer spielt denn bitteschön Fullscreen?
Nee, Moment.
Konnte das Spiel überhaupt borderless Fullscreen?
Wait a minute.
Konnte das borderless Fullscreen?
Okay, ich spiele jetzt erstmal eine Runde.
Team Switch, please. Server erlaubt es nicht.
Dann versuch neu zu joinen, dann vielleicht.
Wir sind eh total verteilt.
Oh.
So.
Der Chat ist voll am durchdrehen.
Ähm.
Konnte das kein borderless Fullscreen?
Nee, jetzt ist Fullscreen off.
Geht aber immer noch nicht.
Das lügt einfach nur.
Fullscreen ist nicht off.
Lügen-Game.
Nice Spawn-Protection.
Irgendjemand soll gebannt werden.
Warum? Ist Hackerman am Start?
Oh nee, was ist hier los?
Anzeige ist raus.
Ah ja, schön diffusen.
Diffuse-Champ.
Ja.
Au.
Was ist hier los?
Warum aimt da mehr als einer auf die gleiche Person?
Direkt blocken.
Alles bannen.
Diffuse-Champ.
Nein.
Alter.
Ich muss...
Diffuse-Champ.
Richtig heftiger Hoos-Champ.
Von wo?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was mich hier von wo hittet.
Um ehrlich zu sein.
Aber irgendwas hittet mich von irgendwo.
Ah, da oben ist ein Auto.
Moment mal, ein B.
Von oben?
Nee.
Oh.
Okay.
Hier ist aber grad ziemlicher Druck drauf.
Leute, ich spotte immer noch nicht.
Ich hab's mir mit 2042 abgewöhnt zu spotten.
Und...
Dabei ist das hier das OPste, was man machen kann.
Ordentlich spotten.
Nein, nein, nein.
So, erstmal kurz ausruhen.
Ja, just cool.
Der kommt doch jetzt hier rum gleich. Der kommt doch jetzt hier rum gleich.
Der kommt doch jetzt hier rum gleich.
Okay, das Problem an der ersten Base Demavent Peak ist,
die artet halt auch relativ schnell in Spawnrape aus.
Wenn man mal die Gegner ordentlich zurückgepusht hat.
Hallo, Game!
Nice. Hätte das immer schneller funktioniert.
Du hast damals angefangen mit Battlefield 3,
Athlon 2, GeForce GT 520,
30 FPS Enjoyer.
Auf der Xbox lief das ja noch nicht mal mit...
Also, auf der Xbox lief das weder mit 720p,
noch mit konstanten 30 FPS.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt, wie ich den Krempel damals überhaupt spielen konnte,
realistisch betrachtet, aber...
Tja, aus irgendwelchen Gründen...
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen...
fand ich das Game trotzdem geil.
Obwohl ich quasi keine FPS hatte und
keine ordentliche Auflösung und nix.
Das Gute ist, dass man nicht so eindrucksvoll ist.
Weil man einfach zu hinten ist, weil man die ganze Zeit über so Zeug drüber springt.
Ja, 64 Spann Rush ist zu viel.
Ich guck danach auch mal nach einem anderen Server.
Aber ein paar Runden spielen wir nochmal, wir haben ja Zeit.
Wo ist er?
Wo ist er? Alter, geh fort.
Oh, ne.
So, wenn ich hier zu lang rausgucke,
ist direkt...
Wenn du hier einmal zu lang peakst...
Alter, wie kommst denn du her?
Wo...
Ist der einfach bei uns in der Base?
Backrage!
Katschibass!
Okay, das war ne dumme Idee, hier rauszustelzen.
Das, ähm,
ist wieder so ne dumme Demo-Wand-Peak-Runde.
Das artet schon in halbem
Spawn-Rape aus der...
...Attacker.
Aber noch geht's.
Noch ist es halbwegs im Rahmen.
Also, die können...
Die kommen ja immer noch rangepusht und alles.
Ach, da oben sind sie!
Haben die das denn jetzt geschafft?
Glaubste? Ich glaub's ja net.
So, ich bleib hier.
Wenn wir jetzt alle rüberrennen zu B...
Man denkt ja immer nur, man ist der einzige, der es selbst reißen kann, ne?
Aber wenn man alle rüberrennt,
dann sind sie hier halt easy durchgepusht.
Weisse?
Dabei geht's auch ohne Probleme so.
Konnte man hier nicht irgendwie sogar rauf?
Ich glaube... Ich glaube...
Das testen wir jetzt mal. Ich glaube, das ging.
Spawn-Bash-Enjoyer.
Aber so sollte man das eigentlich nicht machen.
Weil dann ist ganz schnell
Ragequit angesagt bei den Attackern.
Haha!
Die Zeit ist abgelaufen.
Ja, das ist das Dumme an der ersten
Base von Damavand Peak.
Das ist richtig blöde.
Oh, jetzt pushen sie!
Jetzt pushen sie aber gut hier.
Gachi, push!
Was?
Was war das?
Schneiber-Man hat mir
den Fuß geschneibt.
Okay, ich glaube, wir haben's abgewehrt.
Pass auf, wenn das
jetzt hittet,
dann muss ich aber kecken.
Sagen wir mal, geiert das halbe
Gegner-Team hier nur... Na gut, nein.
Die geiern auf alle.
Das ist halt das Problem des Attackers-Teams,
dass, ähm...
Da ist noch einer.
Das Attacker-Team ist halt...
Hat zu viel Schiss.
Oh Mist, das war...
Das Attacker-Team hat halt zu viel Schiss.
Wie?
Das ist mein Team hier?
Und jetzt... Oh, jetzt können wir sie
abfacken, Leute. Jetzt können wir sie
richtig abfacken.
Wir klauen uns ihren Cheap.
Jetzt können wir sie richtig abfacken, Leute.
Ich sag's euch.
Einfach hier mit dem Cheap stehen bleiben.
Jetzt können sie nicht mal mit dem Cheap spawnen.
Guck mal, wie es einschlägt die ganze Zeit.
Aber die Runde ist ja gleich vorbei.
Alter, der
Bänder-Baba will's aber echt wissen mit seinem
Schneiber-Zeug.
Lass mal auf nen leeren 32-Mann-Server
gehen. Das ist ne gute Idee.
Aber erstmal will ich gucken,
was nach dieser Runde kommt.
Oh. Erstmal
gucken, was nach dieser Runde kommt.
Wenn dann nämlich Zen-Crossing kommt, dann spielen wir die
noch. Ansonsten machen wir den Server voll mit
dem
gutesten Chat auf Twitch.
Nach dieser Runde kommt Attacker-Rückrunde.
Ja gut.
Wir rutschen mal schnell drüber.
Au.
Hoff ich mal.
Sag mal.
Hat der Mörser-Kerl nix besseres zu tun,
als einfach nur
auf mich seine komischen Mörser
am Arsch der Welt abzuballern?
Im Prinzip ist das,
Leute, das ist eh nur noch Aussitzen jetzt.
Sag mal.
Läuft das Spiel? Kann das Spiel nicht mit
mit
Fullscreen, Fullscreen
off?
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das geht glaub ich nicht.
Ich glaub, das hatte kein borderless
Fullscreen, oder?
Ich glaube echt, das hatte kein borderless Fullscreen.
Weil das ist dumm, wenn das kein borderless
Fullscreen hat, dann kann ich gar nicht
irgendwelche sinnlosen
Sachen einblenden
oder so. Und das ist ja
unglaublich wichtig.
Wie wir alle wissen.
Oh, was ist hier los?
Ah!
Lull! Das, das war ein Hit!
Das war angeblich ein Hit!
Ja, ich mein borderless
window, genau.
Borderless window
meine ich.
Das soll ein Hit gewesen sein gerade.
Ich hab irgendwo einfach random in die Luft gesprayt
und er ist gestorben.
Ey, ich mein, ich hab schon
in die Richtung geschossen, aber
war garantiert nicht drauf.
Hackerman.
Hacks activated. 25 Jahre
altes Game. Ja, okay, nicht wirklich ganz.
Wie alt ist das jetzt? 11 Jahre?
11 Jahre?
Ich glaub, 11 Jahre, oder?
Game, please, come on.
Ja, ja.
Oh!
Ich hab's nicht mehr raus geschafft.
Grün gleich FPS.
Ja, korrekt. 10 Jahre alt, 10 Jahre alt.
Grün in das Game frisst
ja nix. Ich glaub, mehr als 200
FPS kann man gar nicht haben in Battlefield 3.
Ich mein,
ich hab einen 240-Hertz-Monitor
und ich hab
V-Sync aus, also insofern, ich glaub, mehr geht nicht.
Ohne Scheiß,
Leute, so
ultra viel schlechter als 2042
sieht das jetzt auch nicht aus.
Von der Performance
her halt ganz zu schweigen, ne?
Aber,
2042 hat halt
die deutlich neuere Engine und könnte
sicherlich, wenn die sich Mühe gegeben hätten,
die Karten
detailliert und schön zu machen
deutlich besser aussehen. Ich mein, guckt euch
Battlefield 5 an. Battlefield 5
war wirklich, und auch Battlefield 1, aber
gerade Battlefield 5 hatte schon sehr
hübsche so
Szenerie, ja, sehr, sehr
hübsche Maps und Hintergründe
und Details und so. Das war
schon nice. Battlefield 5 sieht schon viel, viel
cooler aus als Battlefield 3. Aber es ist jetzt
nicht so, als wären da irgendwie Welten dazwischen.
Das Problem ist, dass es kacke aussieht,
weil es halt keine Details hat
und die keine Mühe
reingesteckt haben. Okay, die Runde war
jetzt nicht sonderlich spannend. Defense,
erste Base, easy win.
Nice.
Ich würde sagen,
GG Eats, auf geht's.
Bashing, direkt ins Auto rein, direkt ins Auto rein,
Leute. Kommt her, volle Pulle.
Ich fahr euch in die Base
und ihr macht Gachi Buzz mit den
Gegnern.
Auto-Route, Leute.
Nein, nein, nein. Hier, da vorne, vor uns,
vor uns, vor uns. Bam.
Ich hab ihn überfahren.
Aber die Leute sind zum Glück ausgestiegen.
Der Schneiber-Typ.
Erst mal richtig drübergerollt.
Wie gut auch der Sound ist,
ne?
Pok, pok, pok, pok, pok,
pok.
Da kommt was, da kommt was, Leute.
Wie gut auch einfach
der Sound ist in dem Game.
Oh, oh, Gachi Buzz, Gachi Buzz.
Oh. Nein.
Zu spät. Und es hatte
tatsächlich einen ganz guten Singleplayer. Ich mein,
der Singleplayer ist jetzt nix, wo ich sagen
würde, ja, da denk ich in 100 Jahren noch dran, jetzt
übertrieben gesagt, aber es ist
durchaus in Ordnung gewesen, der
Singleplayer. Ich finde, von allen Battlefield
Singleplayer hatte der die beste,
die beste Story immerhin.
Sag mal.
Wow. Da hab ich
nämlich gerechnet, dass so viele hier drum rumstehen.
Die Jetmission war
richtig nice von der Optik her.
Vom Gameplay her war die Jetmi-
War die Jetmission
pepega.
Ich aim jetzt einfach die Ecke ab, bis da einer rauskommt.
Ich kann nicht
raus. Okay. Ich hab unten
links jetzt auf mein Team geguckt, wo einer vorbeigelaufen ist.
Okay. Pass mal auf,
hier kommt bestimmt gleich was.
Einfach easy, easy,
easy abaim. Einfach, einfach, einfach
Ecke, wie in CS. Guck mal, wir
spielen das jetzt wie CS.
CS musst du ja auch permanent, wenn
du um die Ecken läufst.
Irgendwie gucken.
Und in CS läufst du halt dann so um die Ecken. So.
Ui.
Die Maus funktioniert ohne Probleme.
Also, wenn man schon anfängt dummes Zeug
zu machen, dann sieht man,
dann sieht man das, glaube ich,
mein Team gerade ziemlich owned.
So, wann konnte man
denn rausrennen überhaupt? Jetzt schon?
Jetzt schon? Ah, ne.
Man hätte vorher rausrennen können.
Auf, rauf hier.
Ne, wo, wo, Moment, Moment, wo war das
nochmal, wo man hoch konnte? Hier?
Man konnte ja den, also,
die Pros sind ja außen gelaufen, ne?
Hm. Nicht irgendwie
da innen. Da innen rennen bloß die Noobs.
Und außen, da sind
auch die ersten, die vom Heli gebasht werden.
Was?
Alter, der Bender-Babber,
Mann. Was ist denn mit,
was ist denn mit dem Dude los?
Das ist Original Battlefield 3,
ja.
Oh, das ist aber ein sehr,
soll ich sagen, sehr optimistisches
Spawn-Beacon.
Oh, oh.
Sehr optimistisches Spawn-Beacon.
Äußerst optimistisches Spawn-Beacon.
Ich, ich würde es dem
mal gar nicht unterstellen, dass der hier krassen
Hacker-Stells macht. Zen-Crossing, please.
Zen-Crossing,
please.
Die nächste, also die Base hier
finde ich übrigens extrem schwer.
Äh, wenn man einen guten Heli-Mann hat, dann
geht's klar. Also, wenn man dann den Heli
bekommt. Weil ich mir gar nicht
sicher bin. Die Defender haben den Heli-Spawn hier, ne?
Genau. Aber ansonsten ist die Base
finde ich, also wenn die Gegner auch nur
halb, hallo?
Halbwegs
kompetent sind, finde ich die Base hier wirklich
schwer. Ich muss, ich muss glaube ich mal,
ach nee, ich war zu früh.
Smoke,
Smoke einpacken.
Ach, guck mal, wir sind ja hier schon durch.
Ah, ja, ja, die Defender haben den
Heli, den Heli-Mann.
Okay, wir brauchen ein bisschen Smoke.
Ja, das Flankieren ist halt auch so ein Ding
gegen den Heli. Wenn du einen guten Heli gegen dich hast
und die Gegner halbwegs kompetent spielen, ist das hier
also ist schon
schwierig. Warte mal,
wo war denn der Kram jetzt hier nochmal? Da, hier
Smoke. Die nächste Base
geht dafür dann wieder.
Eigentlich müssten wir den Heli
geiern irgendwie.
Drei Leute mit Stinger, genau, wir müssten eigentlich den
Heli bisschen geiern.
Ja, super, jetzt haben sie mich gespottet und können durchschießen.
GG Spotting.
So, und jetzt?
Nein, nein, man muss ja nicht hier rum. Guck mal, man kann,
also wenn man gut ist
und das geschickt macht, geht man da rum.
Das Problem ist, dass da auch schon 20.000 Gegner
sitzen.
Da machst du ja nix, ey.
Da machst
du nix. Ah, ich wollte
ja Heli-Geier machen mit der, mit der Stinger.
Die Base ist aber auch,
finde ich, echt eines der schwersten. Also
es gibt, es gibt aber noch härtere Dinger.
Beispielsweise erste Base
Sandcrossing im, im,
im Hof. Wisst ihr, welche
ich meine?
Was ist da, Battlefield? Gut, GG.
Die Base
im Hof, die ist krass.
Die haben ein Auto am Start.
Okay, kein Schimmer,
was hier gerade abgeht, aber Smoke.
Smoke geht ab. Okay, jetzt ist mein
Smoke all. Smoke, Pepega.
Pepega, Smoke.
Aber die Gegner stellen sich halt halbwegs kompetent an.
Da kommst du hier kaum durch. Das ist wirklich heftig.
Aber wir sind, wir sind eigentlich ganz gut dran.
Ich meine, du, auf der anderen Seite brauchst du halt
einen guten Push und es ist vorbei,
ne?
Oh, wir sind dran.
Hohoho.
Weggesprayt von hinten.
Ja, wir müssen es probieren. Du kannst
im Prinzip nur Heli weggeiern
und
Smoken. Was anderes kannst
du nicht wirklich machen.
Ich geh jetzt mal unter die Heligeierer.
Da machst du nicht so viel.
Das ist doch eine Drohne.
Moment.
Das geht?
Ich, ich wusste
bis heute nicht, dass man...
Lull?
Das war mir nicht bewusst.
Ja, Heli, verpiss dich.
Ich geier dich ab. Ich sag's dir.
Ich geier dich weg.
Ich geier dich sowas von weg, Heli.
Komm da raus.
Heli, ich geier dich so weg.
Jaja, Heli.
Ich geier dich so hardcore weg.
Jetzt sind sie am kotzen.
Das mögen die.
Das mögen die nicht, die Heli-Spieler.
Stinger ist so...
Das Ding schlechthin.
Da wirst du auch immer geflamed im Chat
flirtern.
Also, Stinger hat man auch wenigstens,
weil der Heli nervt.
Pyfab-Time.
Was denn sonst?
Und der Heli quasi der Hauptgrund war,
dass wir die Base fast nicht gekriegt haben.
Easy.
Wisst ihr? Kaum ist der Heli weg.
Und da sagt mal einer,
ich würd nicht fürs Team spielen.
Ich mein, ich hab mich hier sacrificed voll
fürs Team die Runde.
Was ein Satz wieder.
Was ein bescheuerter Satz.
Ich hab mich sacrificed fürs Team, ja?
Alles klar.
Habt ihr verstanden, was ich mein?
War hier nicht, war hier nicht irgendwie
nen...
Ich bilde mir ein, hier war ne Medipack.
Dann setz dich auch in Heli.
Nö.
Ich rieche da angepisster Heli-Pilot
irgendwie so ein bisschen.
Im Chat grade.
Die Battlefield 3
Soldatensprüche sind halt auch so pock.
Quit fucking around.
Wir fucken nicht around.
Wenn schon Gachi
busten wir.
Okay, ich dachte er sitzt in der Ecke.
Oh, wir sind
wieder am Start.
Easy, guck mal hier. Kaum ist der Heli weg.
Bam, instant win.
Wir sind auf dem Dach hier, hm?
Jetzt hab ich natürlich ne Kackklasse.
Ich glaub ich muss mal was aufheben.
Das ist jetzt halt so ziemlich das Blödeste, was man da hat.
Was man haben kann für den Tunnel.
Aber wenn wir schnell sind...
Oh, der hat die pock-Posi.
Leute, das ist die beste Posi
hinterm Truck.
Okay, jetzt wieder was ordentliches rein spawnen.
Hinterm Truck ist halt richtig brutal.
OP.
Wow.
Oh.
Der Terminator geht ab.
Wonka.
Die Spaß.
Headshot mit der Spaß.
Spaß-Headshot.
Das muss jetzt sein.
Da sind wir.
Leute, da sind wir.
Lege Henne am Start.
Oh, ich seh nix.
Da kommt doch gleich was.
Lege Henne.
Nice.
Drüber.
Oh.
Wo kommst denn du her?
Alter.
Oh.
Can't wait.
Can't wait, man.
Wow.
Oh, Mist.
Gerade im Falschmoment aufgestanden.
Ne, Slug Money vermiss ich echt nicht.
Slug Money vermiss ich nicht.
Und ganz ehrlich,
das Game ist nicht perfekt.
Das muss man ja auch echt mal sagen.
Auch Random Suppression und manche Sachen,
die bis heute verbuggt sind.
Aber trotzdem, jedes Mal, wenn ich das Game spiele,
hab ich Bock drauf.
Ja, das ist...
Das ist einfach Poggers, das Game.
Fuck.
Ich wollte außer Line of Sight laufen.
Einfach Massive Pog.
Haben wir die Base?
Ach, wir haben die Base.
Easy Win.
Easiest Win.
Würde ich fast schon sagen.
So, die letzte Base ist nochmal ein bisschen schwieriger.
Aber die schwerste haben wir.
Die zweite ist die schwerste.
Wo man da über das offene Feld laufen muss.
Guck mal, das Stripes ist am Start.
Pogu.
Haben wir Pogu
überhaupt noch aktiviert im Chat?
Pogu check, please.
Pogu check.
Pogu ist nicht mehr aktiviert, Leute.
Jetzt haben wir verloren.
Pogu muss aktiviert sein.
Pogu im Chat, genau.
Im Ingame Chat in Battlefield.
Ja, da ist Pogu mit Sicherheit aktiviert.
Battlefield Ingame Chat,
Pogu check, please.
Aha, kriegen wir den noch?
Ja, bleib da.
Nice, nice, nice.
Hier kommt er.
Manchmal weißt du in Battlefield 3 auch nicht so genau,
wo du hin
definieren musst, dass du es findest.
Oh, ein KS, Alter.
Ich hab ihn gesehen.
Vergiss das einfach nur.
Die sind hartnäckig
an der letzten Base, Leute.
Das habe ich gewusst, dass du zurückkommst.
Das war mir so klar.
Das mag ich auch an Battlefield 3.
Das ist irgendwie...
Oh, fuck, hier sieht man...
Alter, man sieht ja gar nichts.
Dass man das irgendwie predikten kann,
was die Gegner machen.
Der Server ist gerade wieder heftig überlastet.
Die Gegner und eigene Leute
klitschen schon durch den Boden durch wieder.
I get fucked up the ass over here,
sagt er.
Und weg, pepega aimed.
Aber die letzte Base...
Also komm, wenn wir die zweite Base geschafft haben,
müssen wir die letzte Base eigentlich auch schaffen.
Die zweite ist viel schwerer.
Guck mal, wir packen mal wieder
unser...
...Smoke auf.
Smoke ist einfach MVP.
Wenn man nicht durchkommt.
Chat oben.
Übrigens, guckt euch mal den Chat oben an.
Das ist doch gar nicht so wild, oder?
Klar wird da ein bisschen geflamed,
aber es ist jetzt nicht so,
als wäre das so ultra toxic,
dass permanent die Mutter beleidigt wird,
dass man nicht durchkommt.
Ja, ne, keine Chance.
Okay, ich komm nicht hin.
Ich hab Schiss, Leute.
Ich hab richtig Schiss.
Keine Ahnung, wo hier gerade was abgeht.
Ich smoke...
Nein!
Ah, äh.
Wir haben gelegt?
Das hab ich gar nicht mitbekommen in der Zwischenzeit.
Die Legehände, easy clap.
So, Brage, Leute. Brage für Zen Crossing.
Brage.
Wenn genug Leute im Chat bragen,
Zen Crossing 64...
Ah, ja.
Brage.
Wenn Zen Crossing durch ist,
suchen wir uns einen anderen Server.
Das ist nicht Level 25.
Das ist Kernel Level 25.
Ach so, meinst du das ja.
Ach so, nee, nee, das ist ja nicht hoch.
Das stimmt schon.
Das ist auch nicht hoch, Kernel 25.
Das liegt daran,
ich hab ja die meisten
Spielstunden
Rush Bazaar 64
Hm.
Hab ich da damals auf der Xbox gespielt?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, 400 Stunden auf der Xbox oder so.
Oh, nee, ich hab Smoke dabei.
Fuck, das war ziemlich dumm.
Äh.
Wo sind wir?
Smoke Defense
Mann ist ziemlich pepega.
Haha, rekt.
Moment, war das dieser
Granatwerfer,
Granatwerfer, Handgranatenwerfer
Launcher? Dieses Ding, was niemand,
aber auch wirklich absolut niemand
spielt?
Seh ich das richtig, ja?
Was zum Geier ist denn hier los?
Okay, die haben uns
ganz schön geschreckt jetzt.
Würd ich mal sagen.
Die haben uns ganz schön
gebumst am Anfang.
Alter, hier machst
du nix.
Ach, der hat über meine Klasse genommen.
Ey.
Vergiss es.
64 Schmidt,
64er Grand Bazaar Server.
Monark S.
Da stirbt
nix von? Please?
Ich leb auch keine
5 Sekunden.
Heftiger Monark S. stellt's hier.
Aber jetzt endlich mal ordentliche, ordentliche
Waffe.
Ich find Grand Bazaar Defense,
die Base ist ganz gut zu defenden,
aber die nächste find ich richtig krass zu defenden.
Die nächste kommst du eigentlich kaum durch.
Wenn die einen nicht direkt am Anfang überrennen
und irgendwie dann was
falsch läuft.
Fall back,
Blyat, Blyat.
Gekomret.
Alter, was ist mit den Dudes
los?
Geht hier alles mit rechten Dingen zu?
Wenn der Baba ist down.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich lass dich nicht retzen.
Was?
Alter, der Captain Peng Anzeige ist raus,
Mann.
Dismodding, Dismod.
Demod.
Mit der Pumpe sind sie
am Start hier.
Oh Gott.
Grand Bazaar can't wait.
Was haben wir denn?
Ich hab keine Gadgets.
Leute, ich hab, ich hab
keine Gadgets.
Irgendjemand spielt hier ne Klasse komplett ohne Gadgets.
Überhaupt.
Kann ich den hier aufheben?
Jawoll.
Noch ein Shotgun-Dude, Mann.
Was ist mit den Shotgun-Leuten los?
Oh, ich dachte mir vielleicht.
Eieieiei.
Please nicht retzen.
Oh Gott.
Lasst mich in Ruhe.
Lasst mich einfach liegen.
Ich will respawnen.
Ja, nice.
Erhalten wir die hier gerade?
Komm, ein Stückchen zurück.
Ein Stückchen zurück.
Also, hier muss man sich tatsächlich
ein bisschen aufsplitten, aber ich finde,
es ist einfacher die Mitte zu halten
als die Straße.
Aber meistens ist es so,
dass auch mehr Gegner
die Mitte pushen.
Also das heißt in dem Sinn,
ich geh mal auf die andere
Seite.
Und wenn die die Mitte pushen,
dann
hoffe ich, dass ich es mitkriege.
Okay, hier ist schon verloren eigentlich.
Also zumindest die Straße.
Wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen an die Ecke.
Hier vorne ist
immer noch gut.
Conquest ist hier tatsächlich ganz nice.
So, erstmal schön
spotten.
Bitte was?
Bitte was? Shotgun, Slug, Headshot?
Oh, der Pantsman ist da.
Der Pantsman
ist da, Leute.
Ich verpiss mich hier mal.
In der Mitte sterben auch ein paar Leute.
Erstmal alles suppressen, was
geht.
Da ist übrigens jetzt die Top-Posi.
Zwischen POG.
Ich geh mal in die Mitte gucken, was da so abgeht.
Das ist Madge.
Ja, nach der Runde suche ich
einen, suchen wir uns einen neuen
Server.
Nach der Runde suchen wir uns einen neuen Server.
Machen einen neuen Server voll.
Wusste ich doch.
Ich seh nix, Leute.
Wie ich einfach mal wusste, dass da was ist.
Ein
nicer Wallhack.
Alles klar, alles klar.
Obvious, was hier gerade passiert.
Komplett logisch.
Komplett logisch. Überhaupt keine Frage.
Also Chat, ich glaube euch
ist auch allen klar, was gerade passiert hier.
Vollkommen easy
durchzublicken.
Easy as fuck.
Der Chat, wer die Map in 64 mag,
ist kaputt. Ja, stimmt schon.
Das stimmt schon.
Alter.
Weee. Vielleicht hätten wir was.
Hier, blickst du wirklich
nochmal durch. Easy.
Einfach, einfach auf rote Punkte.
Einfach auf rote Punkte schießen.
So ist das top.
Easy, einfach rote Punkte schießen.
So.
Beste Pose am Start wieder.
Einfach mit der M16
in eine Richtung schießen.
Das ist absolut Highskill hier.
Das soll mir keiner was anderes sagen.
Kann nicht jeder.
Da musst du schon das Game
mindestens 1000 Stunden
plus gespielt haben, dass du das
auf die Reihe kriegst.
Achtung, wir rushen da jetzt rein.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
Sadge.
Die sind doch immer noch dahinten drin.
Wusste ich doch.
Vielleicht euch das klar,
wo die stellsten.
Was, die haben gesetzt?
Wait a minute. Can't wait.
Wie können die die Legehände hier machen gerade?
Ihr könnt doch nicht einfach
Legehände hinter meinem Rücken machen.
Das glaub ich doch jetzt nicht.
Das glaub ich nicht.
Da machen die einfach Legehände.
Einfach hier sitzen und gerade
aufschießen.
Highskill Gameplay, Leute, hier.
Richtig excellent
Highskill Gameplay.
Und dieser Screenshake.
Oh, weggerotzt.
Wie man hier einfach nur, guck mal.
Einfach nur geradeaus.
Einfach nur geradeaus sprayen, Mann.
Einfach nur geradeaus sprayen.
Da ist nix dabei.
Guck mal, da lebt wieder einer.
Ich hab's zocken sehen.
Haha.
Das ist so dumm.
Highskill, Leute.
Highskill Cap.
Haben wir's bald?
Ich hoffe, wir haben's bald.
Guck mal, da sind noch welche.
Da sind noch welche.
Komm, streck deinen Kopf raus.
Jawoll.
Also, by the way, ich hab keinen dieser Kills
wirklich irgendwie verdient.
Ich schieß ja im Prinzip immer nur auf einen Punkt geradeaus.
Oh, jetzt kommen die C4-Jungs.
Achtung, jetzt wird gepusht.
Push-Action, pusherino.
Nice.
Wie wir sie back gepusht haben.
Gachi-Buzz.
Gachi-Buzz, weggepusht haben wir sie.
Oh oh.
Okay, das ist ein Bug.
Das sieht aus wie ein Gegner, ist aber kein Gegner.
Man kann's ja mal probieren.
Okay, wir haben's gleich, Leute.
Danach suchen wir uns einen 32-Mann-Server.
Und machen den voll.
Weil auf Bazaar-Attacker-Runde
noch mal, nee, nee, nee.
Es reicht, es reicht.
Premium-Map.
Ja, die Map ist halt nix für 64-Mann.
Also, 64-Mann-Conquest geht eigentlich.
Aber was halt überhaupt nicht geht,
ist 64-Mann-Rush.
Ach komm, wir gucken mal,
was auf der anderen Seite der Map geht.
Alter.
Irgendwas im Hals stecken.
Gachigasm.
Gib ihm.
Easy.
Okay, Leute, wir suchen uns jetzt einen neuen Server.
Ich bleib mal hier drinnen.
Und mal gucken, was es gibt.
Refresh.
Also.
Irgendwas, was halbwegs...
Irgendwas mit gutem Ping.
Und was leer ist.
Wir können auch einfach auf ein 64-Mann-Conquest.
Zeig mal her, was haben wir denn für gute Rush-Server?
Gibt nicht so viele, Leute.
Okay, empty, empty.
Alter, es gibt ja...
Was ist denn das?
Es gibt ja kaum Rush-Server noch.
Oder ist die Suche verbuggt?
Jaja, ich suche ja einen leeren.
Hm.
Free for all.
Pick Rush. Nur Demo, wenn Pick Rush.
Nee.
Leute, ich fürchte, es gibt keinen Server mehr, auf dem wir spielen können.
Suchen wir mal...
Suchen wir mal einen leeren...
Suchen wir mal einen leeren Conquest-Server.
Wo wir drauf können.
Nee, Venice kann ich nicht machen.
Die meisten Leute haben hier keinen Venice installiert.
EU.
Russia.
Conquest Lodge, Caspian Borders.
No rules.
Die Map-Rotation suckt.
Nostalgia-Server.
Naja, die Map-Rotation ist jetzt
auch nicht so geil.
Ähm...
pcgamer.com.
Aber ich habe einen 15er Ping auf einem United-States-Server?
Best-Hit-Rack.
Alles klar.
Nee, ein 32er Conquest?
Das ist blöd.
32er Rush gibt es keine.
Kann man hier suchen nach...
Gamesize?
Okay.
Was haben wir hier zu bieten?
Viel ist es ja nicht.
Hier, den konnten wir nehmen.
BF3 Birthday.
10 Years of PC BF3.
Bazaar, Karkent, Firestorm, Death Valley.
Na, meinetwegen.
Ähm...
Das erscheint mir doch als
ganz sinnige Mischung.
So eine Mischung aus allem Möglichen.
Also hier.
BF3 Birthday, 10 Years BF3 PC.
Join.
Die DLCs hat glaube ich fast jeder.
Aber die waren ja nicht sogar kostenlos mit Premium.
Ey, da ist es immer welche gibt, die sie nicht haben.
Okay, aber die meisten haben glaube ich
die DLCs.
Ja, aber einen anderen sinnigen Server gibt es ja hier nicht.
Sonst hätte ich einen anderen genommen.
Na, danach noch mal gucken.
So Leute, auf geht's.
Nachibass.
Wisst ihr, was das Schlimme ist?
Die Straße hier, die sieht detaillierter aus
als Straßen in Battlefield 2042 Maps.
Oh, scheiß drauf.
Versucht das Battlefield Theme zu
MG'en.
Aber das geht nicht richtig, oder?
Funktioniert nicht wirklich.
Au!
Pass auf, wahrscheinlich habe ich jetzt
die ganzen Ultra Pros hier drauf.
Düdüdüdüdüdü.
Ey, das hat ja keinen Sinn
in den LLV zu rennen, Leute.
In den LLV rennen ist ziemlich
pepega.
Ah, mich juckt's an der Nase.
Aha,
Null.
Wie gesagt, macht ruhig den Server voll.
Wenn wir den Server nicht voll kriegen, dann hat's ja keinen Sinn, dass ich jetzt auf
einen leeren Server gegangen bin.
Was ist mit dem los?
Äh, wie heißt der Server? Das ist der hier.
B, äh, äh, äh, äh,
tja, BF3 Birthday
10 Years of BF3 PC.
Ja, alles klar.
Genau.
BF3 Birthday 10 Years
of BF3 PC.
Easy.
Eats. Eats, Eats, Eats, Eats.
Ah, Moment.
Ich will immer noch rutschen.
Dabei ist Rutschen ja nix mehr hier.
Oder war Rutschen noch nix
in Battlefield 3. Was ich eigentlich auch
ganz gut finde. Ich finde dieses Hüpfen
fast besser als das Rutschen.
Das Rutschen ist so und wir wollen
krampfhaft Warzone sein.
Ich weiß, dass es
Rutschen auch in Battlefield 5 gab.
Aber trotzdem.
Was ist da vorne los?
TKG ich das?
Aber es füllt sich langsam.
Ja, ja.
Gut, Kollege. Ist gut, Kollege. Alles klar.
Alles klar.
Eigentlich wollte ich mal hier hochstelzen.
Siehste? Das dachte ich mir.
Zum Glück und zum Glück
hat er mich nicht getroffen richtig.
Oh, wie er es wusste,
Alter. Gab es das
Rutschen nicht schon in Battlefield 1?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe Battlefield 1 so gut wie nicht gespielt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man da schon rutschen konnte.
Konnte man, Chat? Das müsst ihr wissen.
Konnte man schon rutschen in Battlefield 1?
Lass einen Rutschstelz machen.
Nice.
Jetzt haben wir es.
Gib ihm. Alter.
Monka. Monka S. Was ist denn hier los?
Guck mal. Es sind ja nur 8 Spieler
und es geht übelst was ab. Also die Runde machen wir jetzt.
Oder ich gucke jetzt nochmal
noch 10 Minuten. Aber wenn wir den Server nicht voll kriegen,
dann suche ich mir was anderes. Weil es ist halt
doof. Mein 8 vs. 8
muss nicht sein.
Oh. Fuck.
Da sind ja noch mehr. Was ist
mit euch los? Warum wird hier Gangbang
von beiden Seiten gemacht?
Oh. Von hinten. Fuck.
In the bobbies.
Hey, Leute. Ich glaube, das kriegen wir
nicht voll.
Das kriegen wir, glaube ich, nicht voll.
Ja, es gibt leider keinen anderen Server.
Wobei ich finde, der hat eine coole Map Rotation.
Ja, wenn ihr keine DLCs habt, geht das
nicht. Aber es gibt auch keine anderen
Server. Das ist das Problem.
Was? Wir haben deren LLV? Easy.
Hätte ich mir mal
einen Flank aussparen können.
Oh. Nee, ich würde
die DLCs jetzt nicht kaufen für so ein altes Game.
Nee. Es gibt keine
anderen Server, Leute. Es gibt keine anderen
Server. Wir haben
volle Server.
Aber wir haben keinen leeren Server,
wo man nicht die DLCs braucht.
Meine Lieblings-Posi, Leute.
Beste, beste Posi hier.
Beste Posi. Guck her.
Da sind sie schon.
Habt ihr den gesehen? Ich nicht.
Ich habe einfach nur random in die Richtung geschossen,
weil ich gedacht habe, ich habe was gesehen.
Aber anscheinend war das echt.
Okay, wir müssen das, wir müssen das protecten.
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope.
Ja, es
füllt sich. Es füllt sich.
Es füllt sich.
Fucking this bitch is up.
Oh, da wären die Leute heute ja wieder hardcore
getriggert gewesen, hätten die das in Battlefield
2042 gesagt.
Oh, oh.
Oh shit, ich dachte, ich komme noch um die Ecke.
Ne, ja, den habe ich
auch gesehen. Caspian, Caspian
Border only war das Ding. Ne, ne, nicht Caspian.
Es waren zwei Maps. Caspian Border
und noch irgendwas. Das ist aber auch dumm.
Das will ich auch nicht in der Dauer-Rotation spielen.
Wow. Ho, ho.
FJ,
hast du nicht mit uns letztens Dings gespielt?
Battlefield 2042?
Der Name kommt mir bekannt vor.
Warst du nicht der da mit der
AK-24 da so
abgegangen ist?
Doch, ich glaube, ja. Doch, doch, ich erinnere
mich.
Erinnere mich.
So, mal gucken,
wie es ausschaut.
Wird das noch irgendwie voll kriegen hier?
Eigentlich hat es ja auch keinen Sinn,
sich immer da um die Mitte zu kloppen.
Muss man die anderen Dinger auch capturen.
Oh, Battlefield,
please. Auf,
capture. Gib ihm.
Yes.
Okay, hier vorne wird gebasht.
Mal außen rum flanken.
Ah, 10-10.
Schauen wir mal.
Oh, Gachi-Buzz, Leute. Gachi-Buzz.
Gachi-Buzz.
Fuck.
Ich habe es probiert. Oh, nice res.
Oh, oh.
Ich glaube es nicht.
Die sitzen immer noch da.
Es sind immer noch 10-10.
Wande?
Die leben doch noch.
Ah, guck mal.
Schon wieder noch mehr Spieler.
Ich glaube, wir kriegen das Ding voll.
Granato. Granato.
Ich habe ein Problem.
Ich habe keine Muni mehr.
Das kommt äußerst
selten vor eigentlich in dem Game.
Das kommt wirklich nicht oft vor.
Kann einer droppen?
Ich glaube, wir haben gar keinen
mit Muni-Stealth am Start.
Ja gut, gehen wir mal hier runter.
Ohne 3D-Spotting wäre man lost.
Aber ich finde es trotzdem,
auch wenn das OP as fuck ist mit dem 3D-Spotting.
Oh, von der Seite.
Finde ich trotzdem besser,
als dieses komische
Motion-Sensor gespottet.
In Battlefield 2042 bist du entweder
quasi permanent gespottet
und weißt es nicht so richtig
oder bist aus anderen Gründen
Gachi-Buzz um die Ecke.
Okay, der hat es nicht so.
Fuck.
Ich dachte, ich kann
den Jumpshot irgendwie um die Ecke.
Was ist Gachi-Buzz?
Gib es doch mal ein im Chat.
Ja, das ist eines
meiner Standard-Emotes.
Gachi-Buzz.
Ey, Leute,
wo ist denn die Rex?
Bin ich blöd? Wo ist denn die?
Habe ich die nicht?
Kann das sein, dass ich die nicht habe?
Warum habe ich die nicht?
Weggepatcht.
Au.
Ach, ist das die Koop-Waffe?
Oh nein.
Ich habe wirklich auf dem Account keine Koop.
Na gut. Okay.
Chat, ihr wisst, was demnächst ansteht.
Wir müssen Koop spielen.
Opfert sich einer mit mir Koop?
Jo.
Ging das voll?
Hmm.
Also, sag mal so, Hälfte, knapp die Hälfte
des Servers ist voll.
Aber schon aufgerundet, ja.
Null.
Dankeschön,
OP M16, Keck, Wade.
Oh, tut nichts.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, okay, okay.
Das ist natürlich doof.
Überbande.
Oh, shit. Oh, oh.
Oh, von hinten.
Oh, fuck.
Kommt sich ja vor, wie ein CS hier beim Ecken abamen.
Der Rest.
Aua.
Ah.
Alter, Schneiber, Mann, das war nichts.
So.
Das Ding ist schon krass OP.
Oh, der hat uns weggesprayt,
der Bushwoogie.
G3, A3.
Ich hab hier auf dem Account auch nicht alles unlockt, ne?
Okay, beweg dich.
11, 11. Also.
Egal, wir spielen das
jetzt einfach leicht.
Kriegen wir...
Captain Poggers.
Massive Poggers driving.
Ah, das hast du dir so gedacht.
Hallo.
Massive Skillwaffen.
Skillwaffen only heute.
Ihr seht's,
heute ist nur ein 94,
SCAR,
Sniper,
G3.
Ihr seht heute keine Low-Skill-Waffen
wie M16.
Ausgeschlossen heute.
Only Wins und Only High-Skill.
Wie man gerade gesehen hat.
Au.
Big.
Mit der Magnum.
Oh, in der ASK shootet.
Hehehe.
Brage,
dass wir den Server vollkriegen.
So eine richtig fette
64-Man-Conquest-Runde
mit allen aus dem Chat,
wär schon echt ziemlicher Pog.
Zimmlicher Pog.
Pogge wär das.
Pogge.
Oh fuck, ich hab mich reloaded.
Der ist doch noch da hinten drinne, oder?
Da stellts doch einer von euch hier.
Nö, okay.
Hab nix gesagt.
Okay, die Leute lieben schon wieder.
Das wär doch nix mit vollem Server.
Das ist nicht VU, nee.
Ich hab extra nicht VU gestartet,
weil ich mir gedacht hab, es ist einfacher,
hier Leute zu finden.
No Pass.
Aber es könnten jetzt ja auch mal langsam Leute ausm...
Ja klar, M16.
Nee, heute ist nicht M16.
Weiß gar nicht, wo du M16 siehst.
Ich seh hier keine M...
Ich seh hier keine M16.
Wie heißt der Server?
Ach ja, Leute, hier.
BF3 Birthday 10 Years of BF3 PC.
Link.
Im Chat.
Äh.
Mein Copy-Paste funktioniert nicht.
Mein Copy-Paste klappt nicht.
Eins.
Mein Copy-Paste ist broken.
AF.
Oh.
Also wenn wir das nicht voll kriegen...
In 10 Minuten such ich mir noch für die restlichen Abend was anderes.
Also um 20 nach...
Also, was heißt voll?
Sagen wir mal nennenswert...
Nennenswert, nennenswert gefüllt.
Sagen wir mal 30, 40 plus, Leute.
Ich hab ihn immer gesehen.
Oh oh. Da kommt ein Auto.
Das ist ziemlich...
Ziemlich Painschamp.
Nee, das... Guck mal Leute, den kriegen wir nicht voll.
Den kriegen wir nicht voll, das hat keinen Sinn.
FeelsBadMan.
Spielt zu wenig, Leute.
Seriously?
Seriously? Die sind hinter uns gespawnt.
Lul.
Nice, GG.
Ah, jetzt sind wieder ein paar gejoined.
Alter, die farmen sich hier einen ab.
Oh, das war meine eigene. Haha.
Check, wait.
Nee, wir kriegen das nicht voll, das suckt doch.
Was können wir denn sonst?
Hat jemand noch eine gute Server-Idee, Leute?
Irgendwas?
Weil nochmal 64 Mann Conquest...
Äh, nicht 64 Mann Conquest.
Äh, nochmal 64 Mann irgendwie Bazaar
oder so hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Und auf 64 Mann Metro hält sich
mein Bock auch in Grenzen, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
64 Mann Metro ist
nicht so Enjoyer-Modus.
Was, sind die alle down?
Die spawnen bestimmt jetzt hinter uns.
Haben wir es bald?
Haben wir es, haben wir es bald?
Haben wir es heute nochmal?
Autsch.
Die sollen die DLCs einfach mal kostenlos
verteilen. Ich meine allen Ernstes,
das Game ist 10 Jahre alt.
Wer sich jetzt die DLCs nicht gekauft hat,
wird sich die DLCs auch nicht mehr kaufen.
Oh, da ist ein Auto.
Äh, das ist dumm.
Ich suche mir...
Ich suche jetzt einen anderen Server.
Wir haben quasi seit einer Viertelstunde
die kleinen Spieler-Anzahl.
Ja, ich suche jetzt einen anderen Server.
Was nehmen wir denn jetzt?
Zeigt doch mal her.
Alles. Ich nehme alles, Leute.
Es gibt keinen Server mit dem Base-Game.
Das ist ja das Problem. Dann hätte ich den ja genommen.
Gibt es nicht.
Es gab keinen
64 Mann Conquest-Server mit dem Base-Game
mit einer guten Map-Rotation
und, äh, der leer war.
Der leer war.
Das kriegst du ja auch nicht so viele Leute drauf.
Also, was schna...
Was nehmen wir denn jetzt nochmal für die letzten paar Runden?
Also, Air Legends auf jeden Fall nicht.
Metro-Only auch nicht.
Conquest-Large.
Die Map finde ich jetzt nicht so geil.
Warum gibt es denn da eigentlich einen Server,
was nichts anderes hat
mit, äh, mit der Rotation?
Ich habe es doch probiert,
den Server zu füllen. Es ging nicht.
Iron Storm habe ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Vielleicht gibt es ja nichts.
Es gibt nichts,
was wir spielen könnten.
Haben wir noch einen?
Haben wir noch einen 32
Rush?
Vielleicht.
Nö.
Beer und Rush.
Aber das ist ein Kokona-Server. Da habe ich einen scheiß Ping drauf.
Dammer, wenn Peak und Metro
abwechseln.
Ich guck mal kurz, wie da mein Ping ist, wenn ich drauf bin.
Back Battlefield 3.
Ja.
Ihr habt heute die Auswahl zwischen
Battlefield 2042
und Battlefield 3.
Da habe ich mir so gedacht, weißt du was, wir spielen mal wieder eine Runde Battlefield 3.
Gucken, ob ich einen ordentlichen Ping habe.
Aber ich finde keinen gescheiten Server,
den ich spielen will.
Das ist ziemlich sucked.
115er Ping.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Ganz
bestimmt, ganz bestimmt.
Tja, Leute, es bleibt uns wohl nichts anderes
da übrig, als diesen Müll zu spielen.
Deswegen 64-Mann-Rush.
Was haben die für eine Rotation?
Armored Shield,
Banda, Desert, Alborz...
Ach du große Kacke.
Was ist denn das? Das ist das Sharky,
die einzig gute Map.
Ja, 2042 kannst du voll knicken.
Hm.
Es gibt nichts.
Chat, es gibt nichts.
Conquest Large, eine Map.
Den hier vielleicht, hä?
Wobei das halt krass unbalanced ist.
Den Server kenne ich, da habe ich schon öfters mal drauf gespielt.
Das ist halt wirklich ziemlich
pepega. Egal, wir gehen da jetzt drauf.
Was anderes bleibt uns nicht übrig.
Ja, ja, reconnect. Go, go.
Was anderes bleibt
uns nicht übrig. Ich will jetzt noch 1, 2
Runden spielen.
Wahrscheinlich eine Runde noch.
Dann ist es gut.
Selber hosten.
Das dumme ist,
Battlefield 3 Server selber hosten,
das ist nicht mal gemacht mit
wir klicken 2, 3
mal bei einem Hoster. Du musst
da schon dir ein bisschen Gedanken zu machen.
Also ich meine das nicht nur zu Rotation und sowas.
Du brauchst ja auch ein paar Plugins.
Du brauchst die Plugins für Buns. Du brauchst vielleicht
noch Sniper Limit und sowas.
Das ist, da bist du schon
mal, sagen wir mal, einen halben Tag mit beschäftigt.
Und das lohnt sich im Endeffekt auch nicht.
Weil,
das hat jetzt auch nicht wahnsinnig viel.
Guck mal, sehr balanced.
Sehr balanced, wo wir hier drauf sind. Mega balanced.
Huge balanced.
Oh, oh.
Bam, in den Kopf.
Ach, guck mal, wir haben ja sogar tatsächlich
Bazaar Conquerors 64 Mann.
Na dann, schauen wir mal.
Dann wollen wir mal.
Alter. Äh, was haben wir eigentlich
für ein Perk-Setup?
Haben wir irgendwas...
Okay, das ist natürlich
ziemlich pepega eigentlich, aber okay.
Hä?
Da liegen sie drin.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, warum sind wir
da durchgerannt?
Ja, VU ist dead. Leider.
Leider, muss man sagen, ist VU dead.
Die haben es selbst ein bisschen mit verkackt.
An sich, von technischer Seite her, kann ich
echt nichts negatives sagen. Also, für das, dass es
ein Mod ist, dass es ein Fanprojekt
ist, wirklich, wirklich
an sich richtig gut.
Das Problem ist nur, die hatten halt so
komische Community-Server, die
fast alle gesackt haben. Wo dann teilweise
die Admins sogar die Cheats ausgepackt haben, wenn es
schlecht lief. Und da habe ich mir halt gedacht,
das kann es ja nun wirklich nicht sein.
Wrong KS.
Also, und auch
komische Regeln teilweise. Wir hätten
in Venice einen offiziellen Server machen müssen.
Sag mal, diesen offiziellen Server in Venice
mit guten
Rules, die nicht so weit von Vanilla
weg sind.
Alter, Suppression! Ist ja gut,
Mensch. Ich habe so ein
Problem, ich komme hier nicht weg.
Wohohoho.
Kickweight weggesprayt.
Der Chat, guck mal, da ist
der Chat wieder. Richtig toxic.
Toxic Chat. Jetzt wisst ihr auch, warum
sie ihn abgeschaltet haben in Battlefield 2042.
Ne, die haben
ihn abgeschaltet, weil sie
über, wie soll ich sagen, so
overprotective sein wollen.
Dass Tante Brunhilde sich nicht auf den Schlips
getreten fühlt. Wo spawnen
wir denn jetzt rein? Ja, B. Was anderes gibt es ja
gerade nicht.
Und Suppression, wie gesagt,
Suppression war auch eines der coolen
Sachen, die sie in Venice abgeschaltet haben,
weil sie runterdrehen konnten und
alles.
Alter, was ein Clusterfuck wieder.
Boah, ich komme nicht mal aus der Suppression
irgendwie raus.
Liegt hier irgendein Toter bei mir rum?
Oh, sieht so aus.
Oh, das ist schlecht.
Oh.
Monka! Es!
Oh, oh, oh.
Ihr seht mich nicht, ihr seht mich nicht, Leute.
Nein, nein, nein, hier ist keine Granate.
Keine Granate.
Erst mal in den Kopf.
Wie schnell ist denn der unterwegs?
Das ist doch mal kacke. Also, da müssen wir
woanders, das müssen wir anders
anders angehen.
Komme ich, ob ich hier rauskomme
nochmal?
Ich vermute ja mal nicht.
Ich glaube, hier kann ich einfach nur abcampen
und hoffen, dass ich irgendwann mal sterbe.
Ja, easy, easy
komme ich hier raus. Okay, easy.
Guckt es euch an, zack, raus.
Ja, bam!
Oh,
boah, Alter.
Was ein Cluster.
Aha.
Wir machen Headclitchen.
Nein, nein, da ist der Headclitch.
Oh, oh, gehst du weg da oben?
Oh.
Lass mich please liegen.
Lass mich liegen.
Ich will woanders spawnen.
Ja, ja, lass mich liegen, lass mich liegen.
Ach so, FPS.
Render, draw,
was?
Ja, draw FPS 1.
Denkt man so 180 oder so?
Ja.
Okay, eh.
Ne.
Andere Seite hätten wir gemusst.
So, flank action.
Was machen die denn da?
Da kommt nichts, Leute. Da kommt nichts.
Unsere Leute sitzen gerade im Gang.
Gachi Base.
Also ich kann auch nicht mehr als 200 haben.
Okay, ist natürlich doof.
Jetzt sind die Leute schon am Start hier.
Oh.
F2000.
Okay, vielleicht hätte ich doch bei B bleiben sollen.
Andere Seite, ne.
Ah, ah, ah, ah.
Okay, wo ist hier was?
Vielleicht haben wir Glück und kommen rüber.
Okay, ah, safe.
Safe, nice.
Hallo, ich will rüber.
Vielleicht haben wir nämlich Glück.
Oh, da kommt was, Achtung.
Das waren zwei.
Ja, 200 FPS.
Wie gesagt, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man mehr
stoppen kann als 200 FPS in Battlefield 3.
Keine Ahnung.
Wow, nice.
GG Eats.
Ah.
Was ist im Chat?
Gecomruts im Chat.
Gecomruts am Start.
Oh ne, jetzt verlieren wir wieder alles.
Ich glaube, jetzt müssen wir doch B rein.
Keine andere Chance,
außer Clusterfuck.
Clusterfuck Deluxe.
Alles klar,
obvious, was hier passiert.
Also, wer hier nicht durchblickt,
sollte lieber aninstallen.
Easy, easy.
Easiest Durchblick of my life hier.
Ach, hier geht die Wand kaputt.
Das wusste ich ja noch gar nicht.
Das war mir gar nicht bewusst,
dass hier die Wand kaputt gehen kann.
Meine Güte.
Was ein Clusterfuck.
Keine Explosive Limit.
Ja, five head time.
Was?
Alter, wie?
Was ist hier gelegen?
Ich glaube, der Server ist gerade ein bisschen am verbrennen.
Okay.
Böser Strike.
Wir sollten aber ehrlich gesagt
lieber
Squad Cover nehmen.
Ist besser.
Was zum Teufel
ist mit den Leuten los?
Vielleicht können wir flanken.
Da kommen doch noch mehr, Clay.
Leute, da kommen doch noch mehr.
Passt mal auf.
Oh. Oh.
Okay, der muss im Prinzip nur geradeaus
aimen. Hier, das kannst du nicht contesten.
Das kannst du nicht contesten.
Gescheit hier geradeaus.
Keine Chance.
Der muss einfach nur geradeaus zielen.
Da unten ist einer drin.
Kommen wir vielleicht außen rum?
Ich habe keinen Bock hier auf
die ganze Zeit in diesem Gang rumzurennen.
Das ist ziemlich low IQ.
Und durch eure
ganzen Prime Subs habe ich so hohen IQ,
da kann ich nicht so
diese
low IQ Spielweise machen.
Könnte ich mal sterben?
Nice, wir haben sie.
90 Prozent im Gang.
Ja, das kann auch andere...
Was steckt denn hier?
Was ist denn das?
Da steckt
was drin.
Uh. Ihr trifft mich
nicht.
Easy, ihr trefft mich nicht, Leute. Ihr könnt mich gar nicht treffen.
Wenn sich jetzt
das bewegen würde...
Nein. Nein.
Lasst mich.
Geh weg.
Ach ja, stimmt.
Es gibt ja den 64 Player Mode.
Den wollte ich eigentlich ausprobieren.
Alter,
hier kannst du nicht raus.
Vielleicht habe ich Glück.
Jetzt.
Jawohl. Okay. Okay, nice.
Okay. Okay.
Okay.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ah.
Alter, das ist ja...
Du kannst ja nirgendswohin.
Du kannst ja wirklich nirgendswohin.
Ich habe es jetzt ja echt probiert, mal außenrum
zu kommen.
Im Prinzip bleibt da ja echt nur
Gangstelz hier.
Einfach Gangstelz.
Ja.
Gangstelz. Was willst du machen?
Die haben auch noch einen Jeep auf der anderen Seite stehen.
Und Mörser. Und Mörser
noch am Start. Ja, nee. Das klappt nicht.
Okay, wir flanken. Wir gehen andersrum.
Andersrum.
Wir gehen so rum.
Nicht hier, sondern so rum.
Warum liegen da welche?
Einfach random mitten auf der Map.
Liegen irgendwelche Typen auf der Erde.
Gangway.
Was ist das mit euch los?
Autostelz.
Ja.
Corona kickt wieder.
Leute, Februar wird
Boosterstelz gemacht.
Wenn wir hier rausgehen, sind wir deadge.
Ich sag euch, wie es ist.
Instant deadge.
Richtig, deadge.
Da fährt sogar ein Panzer rum
auf der anderen Seite.
Shit.
Alter.
Es gibt ja keine Ecke, wo du raus kannst gerade.
Okay, YOLO.
YOLO.
Was zum?
Was?
Ach da. Alter.
BTF.
Was ist mit euch los?
Wird einfach in der Ecke rumgammelt.
Oh, was haben wir denn hier?
Ah, ist Val. Ohne Extended Mag.
He's Batman.
Kann ja nix werden.
Ja, wir probieren das mal die Tage aus, Leute.
Wir probieren mal die Tage 2042 wieder aus
mit 64 Mann.
Wo die High-IQ-Leute drin sind.
Als guten Spieler
haben wir nur den Bush Wookie gerade.
Ey, das ist mir zu Painschamp gerade.
Aber habt ihr es gesehen, Leute? Man kann Squad wechseln.
Ist euch das aufgefallen?
Habt ihr es gemerkt?
Was für krasse High-End-Funktionen hier in dem Spiel
auf einmal drin sind?
Also, da muss...
Die haben echt bestimmt so einen Pakt mit dem Teufel
eingegangen in Schweden damals.
Anders geht das nicht.
Ja, natürlich.
Der stirbt davon nicht.
Was? Ein Mörser.
Ne, das
macht gerade auch keinen Bock.
Macht auch nicht wirklich Bock gerade.
Gibt's Game-Notes starting?
Ja, schön.
Ich hab gerade keinen gescheiten Server, den wir spielen können.
Eingescheiten Server...
Firestorm...
32x Rush.
Das Problem ist, diese Server...
Diese Cloverfield-Server sind halt mega krass unbalanced.
Meistens dominatet da eine Seite.
Heftig.
Wieso? Was ist bei der Steam-Version so schlecht?
Achso, ja. Ich weiß, was du meinst.
Dass die Steam-Version keine Steam-Version ist.
Dass die Steam-Version quasi einfach Origin startet.
Ja, das ist richtig dumm.
Ne, Markass-Molulit
bin ich jetzt nicht so scharf drauf.
Kein Schimmer.
Leute, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich glaube, ich lasse es jetzt gut sein.
Gibt ja nix.
Was ist... Vielleicht ist... Pass auf,
vielleicht ist der andere Server
jetzt wieder voll Burster. Ne, der hat 0.
Ja, Battlelog ist auch
Hexenwerk.
Leute, wir sehen uns. Ich geh off. Es gibt nix, was ich
gibt. Keine gescheiten Server gerade und
alles andere,
was es gibt, hab ich keinen Bock
richtig drauf. Da waren die
64 Mann Rush-Dinger tatsächlich
am besten. Bis dann, Leute.
Wir sehen uns. Macht's gut. See you.